this is Startalk juan-carlos out uh
release from facebook says dear mr. Nye
given that the earth experiences ice
ages periodically what will happen to
the next one given the current state of
our climate so we've had ice ages before
yep does this mean that we will not have
another Ice Age or will it mean that
this will precipitate an even greater
ice age what will it do so we have other
stations before so the the peak of the
last ice age was about 20,000 years ago
here in New York City that was pretty
much the edge of the of the ice sheet so
it actually stopped in Brooklyn I'm not
quite sure why it stopped in Brooklyn
but probably for a latte or something
but the those those ice ages the ice age
is driven by the wobbles in the Earth's
orbit which are slow but kind of small
and kovitch Thank You Mitch cycles
that's exactly right
okay guys I'm sorry please expound
because I have been left out
malankov it Yankovic I know is Donald
Trump's wife so I was a Serbian and he
did all these calculations while in jail
for four political activities in Serbia
back in the nineteen back in the 1920s
and so what he worked out was that the
the orbit of the earth around the Sun so
we all know it's an ellipse but the but
the eccentricity of that ellipse
moves in time basically because of the
influence of Jupiter and Saturn what it
does it wobbles and the tilt of the
earth that wobble was a little bit and
the precession of the earth so kind of
where it's spinning around like a wolf
record when a we're in New York it
should be a dreidel if you look at it
okay so like a story so that what was
around so these things wobble on twenty
thousand forty thousand a hundred
thousand years frequencies near interact
and they interact and they they change
how much sunlight gets to the poles how
much them I guess to the tropics and
that helps the ice ages grow and recede
but the interesting thing is there they
have it though they haven't always
happened right they've only been
happening for about the last two and a
half million years and the reason why we
think that they've started happening in
that relatively recent period is because
the carbon dioxide level dropped to her
to a level that allowed I cases to
expand in other words the wobbling was
going on in the past but their
loveliness been gone I was overwhelmed
by the greenhouse effect I didn't it
didn't make a difference because the
planet was so warm in a Cretaceous that
that was really really warm and ancient
dinosaurs running around once and I only
increased sea level was about 80 meters
high of 80 meters yes it's like that
would go from we're on the east coast
the United States that would go where to
Chicago or something now so a lot of the
Mississippi Basin was it was an inland
sea at that point the the sea level in
the Pliocene which is not quite so far
about three million years ago there's
there's a there's a right in the middle
of New Jersey there's the old Pliocene
cliffs but they're a long long way from
the coast now yes yes let's get to this
question the answer is no we're not
going to see any more ice ages the next
one would have been due in about 30,000
or maybe maybe fifty thousand years yeah
you are you are gonna miss it but it's
not going to happen it's not gonna
happen because the the timescale for the
carbon that we put into the system is
hundreds of thousands of years and so no
more ice ages no more ice age that's
really a striking thing everybody no
more ice ages yeah because we make
hilarious jokes about the ice ages I
went to school in the Finger Lakes which
were carved by glaciers
movement south that's not going to
happen anymore those were the days the
glaciers all the glaciers we know going
to go away so almost all the mountain
glaciers
that we know are receding some of them
quite dramatically the only part of the
planet where ice is pretty stable is
East Antarctica which is the the biggest
chunk of ice and that's very cold very
stable and so that's the part that's
that's gonna stick around the longest
but the other bits the ice on the
Antarctic Peninsula Greenland is losing
mass at about 250 Giga tons of water a
year the abbé the West Antarctic Ice
Sheet is losing mass so everybody if you
want to see Glacier National Park see
for its mud slide National Park get
going this is Startalk